all right let's go and react so first
thing we want to clone is the you state
hook it takes an initial value so how do
you how do you define state and set
State how do you implement that we're
going to have state and let's just
assign that to Val for now this is wrong
but
we just get something showing on the
screen and then we'll modify from there
so now we have hooks in node let's use
it these are all standard JavaScript
patterns that are pretty handy when
doing this what I expect is to log out
one and two unfortunately I log out one
and one and that means it's not really
working it actually is that set count is
working it's modifying internal value
but the problem is when I destructure
this counts in the value of one and it
is one here and it is one here that's
why we're logging out one so we need
some place to just repold the internal
State again one easy it's very cheap way
to do it is to turn the state into a
getter function and now I have my
stateful function back again so one and
two and this is kind of hooks in node if
you need Hooks and node that's that's
all the implementation it's eight lines